everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we are in round
three of our coverage of the 2018
canada's tournament from berlin germany
our competitors today whites gonna be
played by Levon Aronian has two draws
coming into round three so he's half a
point behind first place he is trailing
his opponent today Vladimir Kramnik
playing the black pieces he is in tie
for first after having a win in a tie
after his first two round so we'll go
and get into it starts out with pawn to
e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop to
b5 getting into the Rui Lopez but
instead of yesterday where we saw pawn
to a6 and we transitioned into the
closed game we immediately get into the
Birdland offense which is the most
common Rui Lopez variation that we seem
to have been seeing over the past three
or so years and we see LaVon demand play
pawn to d3 now this is not the most
common castling on the kingside is
definitely the most common but decides
to go and play pawn to d3 now Bishop
down to c5 Bishop takes pawn recaptures
and then castle on the kingside Queen to
e7 and this does a couple things one is
it protects this Bishop here honest he
five but it also allows for black to
have the option if he wants to castle on
the Queen side any time there is the
exchange in the right Lopez where the
pawn recaptures here onto c6 it's one of
the few times you'll see black capture
away from the center many times when you
catch with your pawns you're capturing
towards the center instead of away if
you have the option this is one of the
times where you'll normally see black
capturing away so they can have the
option castling on the Queen side having
the rook here on d8 as a symbiote open
file really attacking their opponent so
this Queen to e7 it is developing move
also just kind of waits to see where his
opponent does play and Levon Aronian
plays pawn to h3 this does stop the
bishop coming down here to g4 pinning
down the night and then castling on the
Queen side start to have a strong attack
pushing everything on the King side of
the board
so does stop that threat also Knight
down
g4 is just pretty annoying but we see a
pretty interesting move from Vladimir
Kramnik in he completely goes on the
offensive any place rook here to g8
getting ready to push for it if he wants
to with his pawns definitely signaling
that if he wants to castle it is going
to be on the queenside the board given
up to right to do that on the Kings side
of the board we do see King - h1 which
is you know fairly interesting to see
Levon Aronian already kind of curious
about how he's going to defend this does
not want to have to worry about this
bishop here on c5 pinning down the pawn
on f2 also with the rook here on the G
file I just doesn't want to have to
worry about his king but he's sort of in
retreat mode already he's not developing
his other pieces were black really
developing a lot of his pieces on the
board now Knight to h5 this opens up the
door for the Queen to get involved into
the game if he ever needs to as well as
opens up the door for a strong attack
pushing forward with pawn to g5 now pawn
to c3 getting ready for a push but
really this is just a preparation move
for a later move like pawn to d4 doesn't
really immediately get pieces involved
into the game or strike the center and
force black to respond so we see
Vladimir Kramnik continue with his
gameplay and that's pawn to g5 stay as
aggressive as possible in the game he
feels like he has a strong attack going
on even though it's very early on 9
moved into the RAI Lopez we don't see
this very often in the Birdland offense
usually more of a quiet defense where
blacks just has a very solid structure
doesn't really try to advance too much
just wait to see what white does all of
a sudden 9 moves in the Birdland offense
Vladimir Kramnik is gone on the
offensive now in this position we see
white take than the pawn here on e5 and
this is one of the squares now just I
think you should probably look at this
position and recognize that there's no
way they've Vladimir Kramnik he's going
to just give up this pawn unless there
is a very very strong attack and if
there is
probably should be thinking about
something else after the night takes not
really sure what he's expecting clearly
not going to you know take the night
here on e5
because then just the Queen takes here
on h5 this gets rid of that the biggest
threat that Black has going on and now
all of a sudden we see white is Seth
material that's not gonna happen on
board what we do see is black says yeah
you can have that pawn I'm not worried
about the pawn right now I'm focused on
the big attack and he plays pawn to g4
really trying to blow up this King side
of the board and all the protection in
front of the King
this concept right now you know where
does black go from here you know how
does he respond if we look at it and say
okay what if the knight were to take
here on g4 well now we could say just
the bishop takes and then how does white
respond if he takes with this pawn okay
then the Queen comes down here to each
for and this is going to be a quick mate
Knight down here to g3 this pawn can't
recapture cuz it's being pinned down by
the bishop here okay what if instead of
the the pawn taking there what if the
Queen takes we know we can clearly see
the Queen is going to fall after the
rook takes maybe pawn to d4 attacking
the bishop said both the bishop and the
rook are being captured
but then black can just continue to
sacrifice material rook takes on g2 King
recaptures and now the Queen down here
efore check starting to gobble up more
material and then later if he wants to
you know pawn to f3 Queen down here c2
eventually we see castle on the Queen
side black is able to get the Queen or
the the rook involved into the game have
a comeback few other options because
people always curious what other things
we could see the bishop now is attacking
this Queen so maybe Queen to d2 well
let's put it on this dark square so it's
no longer being attacked right now but
now the bishop could just take here on
h3 yeah we've already looked at what
happens if the the pawn were to take
well that gets that gets very difficult
you get the Queen involved into the game
you know the rook can easily get
involved into the game and you always
have that
night coming down at any point here to
g3 check forcing you know white to do
something that's not gonna be a good
option another option from here we could
see maybe pawn to g3 just trying
something new but now rook takes on g3
could sacrifice pawn takes Knight takes
here this is forking but could decide
just not even going to worry about
taking that that rook since black has
such a strong attack you can see there's
just no great moves in the game if the
knight were to take so we do see Levon
Aronian does not do that and instead
after pawn to g4 he does play pawn to d4
trying to just break up some of the
attack that Vladimir chronics has in the
game but you can see it's so difficult
with so much material aimed at the king
side of the board now we see black play
bishop here to d6 and then g3 do not
want to go ahead and take here on G
force we talked about Queen down h4
that's gonna be extremely bad so we see
pawn up here to g3
Bishop takes pawn takes then the Queen
takes here on e5 this is setting up for
whenever black wants to to take this
pawn on e4 and that would also be
checked so white has to deal with that
place queen up here to d4 says please
exchange material I think I can get down
to an in-game hopefully draw the game
out Vladimir Kramnik recognizes he does
not want to give up his strongest piece
when he has a super stronger attack so
he's gonna retreat bring his queen back
here to e7 very important square because
it also still allows him to come to that
critical square of h4 if there ever is
some exchange here on g4 coming down
here to h4 is just a huge threat so we
see pawn to h4 pawn to c5 from Vladimir
Kramnik attacking the Queen Queen comes
here to a c4 and then Bishop to e6 so
just centralizing this Bishop now it's
go time if flack ever wants to castle on
the Queen side of the board Queen up
here to a b5 check sure pawn to c6 and
the Queen comes back here to a4 and this
is where
I think the Queen really needs to be
more centralized Queen to d3 makes some
sense I mean whites in a tough position
either way but Queen to a4 really takes
the Queen out of the equation here this
is the strongest piece both the rook
here on a1 the Queen here on a4 aren't
doing anything this this night the only
way can really get involved into the
game is to come here to d2 that's gonna
block off the dark square Bishop so it
just feels like a lotta Bernie and has
blocked himself out of the game pawn to
f4 so let's just throw everything we can
at the opponent's King side and you know
would really like to just play pawn
takes on f5 because then the Queen is
open to get involved into the game but
this is gonna be bad Knight takes on g3
if the King comes up here Queen down to
h4 you know if the pawn takes could have
taken before either way then the Queen
could come here but the bishop to d5
check you can see how bad this gets
Queen down here to h2 there's just no
way for what to really deal with this so
was not able to take this pawn as he
would like to plays Bishop aveer to g5
attacking the Queen rook takes pawn
recaptures push those pawns as much as
possible continue to put pressure on
your opponent the Queen comes back to d1
to recognize them it needs to get
involved into the game what's not doing
anything they're on a four rook to the
eight says okay you're on do you wanna
get one I want to get my rook involved
the game I can't castle because you
can't castle through a check so just
says yeah we're over here to d8 my king
here on EI tis completely safe there's
no way you can get material up the only
piece you would actually attack with is
your queen and you really need to keep
that at home base to try to protect the
action Queen here to see one trying to
attack some of this material but
Vladimir Kramnik aside so let's just go
and blow up some material here and you
know if the pawn takes okay well that's
gonna be bad we already know that the
Knights gonna come down here to g3 for
King the rook just gobbling up more
material and then Levon Aronian plays
Knight to a3 that's not necessarily a
bad move he needs to give this other
rook involved into the game also needs
to find a great square for his knights
and he can't bring it to c3 if it brings
it here - d - that's just blocking off
his queen but you can really tell what
desperation
Levon Aronian Xin Vladimir Kramnik
completely crushing the king side of the
board has a strong attack going on and
he's playing knight over here to a three
completely away from the action not
threatening his opponent in any way
shape or form it's not looking good for
the white black comes down to d3 and
then we see rook to d1 just trying to
exchange material Vladimir Kramnik is
not having it he finds a really nice
move here it's the the best move on the
board and really just ends things you
know Levon Aronian does end up playing a
few more moves but feel free to stop it
see if you can find the best move for
black in this position and the move is
Bishop to d5 and it opens up so many
attacks on the board we'll go through
some of them if we look and say okay
what happens if the the pawn takes okay
pawn takes here on d5 but once the
bishop came here from east six that did
open up the door for the Queen to
activate Queen down here to e4 maybe
King g1 pawn takes that's a deadly check
right there it doesn't really matter if
it takes or not it's all gonna be
downhill Knight to g3 check if the King
takes sure it's all gonna look the same
Queen down here to f3 there will
eventually be a checkmate in the game
that's not gonna do it although it looks
like oh yeah you have that that piece of
material here I'll go ahead and take
that can't take that bishop he tries for
pawn to f3 recognizing you know that
that pawn taking here is just a
devastating move so it doesn't want to
deal with that but this fails as well
pawn takes here on f3 now the pawn could
take on d5 doesn't have to worry about
the same mate but he still has to worry
about make Queen down here to e2 there's
no way to really stop this you can see
that the Queen coming over here to h2 is
checkmate so we see white play rook to
e1 and this says you can't move your
queen because it's being pinned down so
we see Vladimir Kramnik say yeah no
problem I'll play pawn to g2 and now
there's just no good move that white has
here he has both of his pawns depending
on where white moves he can eventually
get his knight involvement to the game
he can
pushes pawn one more than his get his
rook involved into the game it's all
going to be very very bad for white so
the thing of the day Levon Aronian
decides to resign Vladimir Kramnik to
the first three games has two victories
and a draw so he is a top of the
leaderboard congratulations to him
playing the Berlin defense I just don't
expect to see someone playing it this
aggressive but he had a game plan he
executed and from the very beginning he
was all over his opponent and never let
up attack the entire game and just
completely overwhelmed Levon Aronian so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
we are gonna be taking a break the
players play three three matches and
then take a day off so the next day will
be a break and then we'll come back for
round number four but thanks for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
video